[Música]
bom dia a todos
hoje eu falar sobre microplásticos o
perigo invisível à saúde e ao meio
ambiente
mas afinal o que são microplásticos
microplásticos são pequenos pedaços de
plástico com menos de 5 milímetros de
comprimento que podem ser bastante
prejudiciais a nossa vida ea vida
aquática onde podemos encontrar os
microplásticos estão presentes em
diversas coisas no nosso cotidiano como
por exemplo o sal marinho cosméticos
água mineral produtos de higiene pessoal
em peixes de espécies humanas entre
diversas outras coisas teste de água
aponta de 90% da minha fala no mundo
está contaminado com micro plástico mas
afinal é seguro beber essas minúsculas
partículas de plástico a resposta não é
simples pois cientista não comprovaram
que realmente é seguro mas sabemos que
não é saudável
mais de 400 tipos de bactérias já foram
encontrados em 275 pedaços de
microplásticos plâncton de pequenos
animais se alimentam no pódio
contaminado e ao serem comidos por
peixes maiores propagam intoxicação mas
com um pequeno pedaço de plástico pode
destruir nosso planeta é simples
entender isso
primeiro nós poluímos assim destruímos
ecossistemas
desse modo acabando com os animais pois
não tem mais habilidade
assim o planeta destruído desse modo sem
provas em alimento e muito provavelmente
sem fontes de água no planeta nos
destrói nossa pirâmide pois ela mostra
como podemos mudar o futuro é simples
entender isso nós estamos passando por
uma queixa por uma transformação por
exemplo dos canudos de plástico a outros
diversos tipos de canudo mais de
degradáveis cada pessoa desse auditório
tem de fazer uma escolha
escolher um canudo muito mais poluente
entretanto mais acessível e outros
diversos tipos de canudo menos poluentes
entretanto menos acessíveis
com essa reflexão podemos impactar
sociedade impacto na sociedade
mudamos o mundo mudamos nosso jeito de
ver o nosso futuro
mas como eu possa erradicar os
microplásticos ele tem várias maneiras
uma delas como disse antes são evitar no
uso do cartão de plástico pois hoje em
dia com a tecnologia que nós temos já
podemos criar diversos diversos outros
tipos de canudo como por exemplo o
cartão de papel o de metal
o de bambu ou de plástico reutilizável e
de vários outros
outra forma também é acabar com o uso
das sacolas plásticas pois elas são
muito perigosas não para a vida aquática
quanto para nós mesmos mas como eu posso
fazer isso
simples o livro ecobags para fazer
compras elas são reutilizáveis e um
preço bem acessível para todos nós
essas são só algumas maneiras de
erradicar os microplásticos ele tem
várias outras
você também pode criar sua basta pensar
sempre no nosso futuro e no meio
ambiente
obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]